Nazi uh welcome to the show we haven't
seen you in a while it was a tough event
up this point but today you uh through a
caution to the win you just wanted to
have fun it felt like was that the
case yes hi guys I've missed you so much
it's been a really long time
true yeah I guess today I felt like
playing very aggressively and figured
neither of us have anything to lose and
let's just play some crazy game and it
worked out pretty well for me yes
absolutely and in fact take us through
your preparation was this H5 and a
couple of Pawns sacrifices part of your
preparation was uh this over the board
how was
it it's all over the board I didn't know
what to do after
B5 absolutely yeah uh I I I did prepare
H4 line but I was just not expecting her
to go into this Bok kind of line so in
the variations I prepared I was uh ready
to sacrifice Pawn on H5 so here I
figured since I already wasn't up an
extra pawn it wouldn't hurt to sacrifice
my own why not why not and that opens
the lines towards her King and uh how
are you feeling about your chances right
now especially after long Castle I
making the move long castle that must
have uh felt quite
good yeah I was very optimistic I'm
shocked to see that it says double zeros
I thought I was much better
yes and where do you feel like you're
finally taking over the
initiative it seems like your play is
much easier she was looking searching
for her counter chances on the queen
side but they just weren't really
happening uh and finally you broke
through and it's still triple zeros by
the way it seems with this move C3 which
is unbelievable and very uh difficult
think that this is
possible but she did not find that she
played the move Queen to F5 and finally
you broke through and this 96 to finish
off things was a very nice touch tell us
a bit about this tournament what went
wrong what are you going to do to adjust
what is your uh attitude going into the
final
round so I started pretty well and then
after the rest day I felt like I forgot
I was playing a tournament I completely
got out of the Zone I guess and I lost
three in a row which uh against Bim yes
she played a really good game and I
deserve to lose but the other two games
I definitely should have not lost so
that was hard to recover from but um I'm
planning to finish strong well you're a
fighter and you showed it so many times
guys any questions for naszi no just a
congratulations on a very very
entertaining game uh Nasi and good luck
we really enjoyed you pushing the pawns
and just trying to attack and Talia on
the other side these games are fun to
commentate on absolutely thank you guys
absolutely as we prepare for